this is the season of graduation kids
are going to die
this is not negotiable
every graduation
people get really excited about
being an adult
and then they die immediately this is
what happens kids go out
they drink too much they get in a car
they do too many drugs
they
ah how else do kids die they race they
drag race
they try to do this dumb internet prank
and they fall off a roof
they're gonna die
the summer senior summer
between high school and college
invariably
kids get
too excited about being an adult they're
like now I'm an adult and I'm gonna do
whatever the [__] I want and some of
them die and it's sad but it is every
year like clockwork that's happened I
remember it I knew people
that senior that senior year one girl I
knew was her boyfriend strangled her
under a bridge that's not technically
her fault
but that's what happens when you're in a
very passionate relationship and some
women should know that
this is sometimes the end I didn't know
them well but this was my senior summer
went and got her
um
that's not you know that's neither here
nor there it's an example of what I mean
is that it's senior summer can either be
very fun or not very fun I you know
senior summer we I just continued to do
what I did for you know during High
School which was just a nice amount of
drugs a reasonable rational amount of
drugs every day I knew my tolerance I
knew my limits
and if there's anybody listening that's
going and having a crazy senior summer
don't overdo it
you have your whole life to use drugs
and drink alcohol
don't overdo it this one summer it's not
worth it and a lot of these deaths
happen to be because you're trying to
impress somebody they're just trying to
impress a friend
or like a um you know a girlfriend maybe
they're like look at me
look who's [__] standing on the big
rock in the and then it's over and they
die quickly
they die very quickly it's it's they're
out
friend of mine's brother just you know
sad but just in a car done
it's not long and agonizing it's quick
and so this dude
he's a baseball player in Baton Rouge
Louisiana
good looking
probably had the world at his feet
nice picture of him and the girl at prom
this guy's living his life
they go on a cruise to the Bahama I
don't even know why
but this is what I guess people in you
know when you're graduating in Louisiana
this is what you do
you go on some Cruise
to uh the Bahamas I think it's called
it's something ridiculous it's called
like uh
the Pirates Revenger something silly
that this guy
ended up going to and there's a video of
him
jumping off I guess everybody's on this
boat it's late at night
and we have the article I believe it's
late at night it's sad this is sad we're
watching someone get eaten by a shark or
we think we are we don't really know
but it's this so he's a U.S high school
graduate he disappeared after leaping
off a cruise ship
into the dark Waters of the Bahamas last
week he might have met a Grizzly fate
with a shark attack
Cameron Robbins 18 was last seen
swimming after chomping off the
Blackbeard's Revenge Sunset Cruise
the Royal Bahamas Defense Force was like
yeah the waters are very shark infested
so now look here is
let's see the the video of this kid
because I think he's trying to show off
and this is what happens
[Music]
wow
let's watch it one more time because
it's dark and it's grainy but there's a
moment in the video when you could see
he disappears I think people are
thinking that he was pulled underwater
by the shark
now that again just before we watch it
again there's a this is a moment in this
kid's life and some of these moments
Define your life
you may not want to hear this I don't
know how many people listen to this show
that are young some of them might but
there are moments that define your life
and you don't even know it like you
don't even know it
it and sometimes it's too late
that guy wanted so badly
to be a badass
to stick out
to get attention
to be seen as a [__]
crazy dude
he want now because they the kids they
watch all these people do pranks and I'm
friends with some of them the Nell kids
and whatever they watch all of this
stuff on the internet and they go
the way to get attention
is to
do a prank that captivates everybody
gets everybody to go dude yo it was
legendary we were in the Bahamas and
Cameron bro he's [__] nuts he's
picturing this at his wedding
he's picturing at his wedding
someone's got his best man's gonna be
like
Cameron hey Jessica you're getting a
[__] crazy guy I was with him when he
jumped off a [__] pirate ship in the
Bahamas everybody thought he was gonna
die there were sharks everywhere but
[__] Cameron he doesn't give a [__]
about anything that's what he thought
the result of this was going to be
that's what I believe he
thought it was going to be
he's like I'm just gonna do it and that
moment defined
his life his entire life now is over
because he thought to himself I'll just
be a [__] badass
for a few minutes
for a few minutes nothing you know I'm
just gonna jump in the water I'm gonna
swim a little bit everybody's gonna
point and instead everybody witnessed
his death at the hands of a shark
which is
pretty [__] cool
not that he died that is sad
but it's actually a much better story
than he had even envisioned he's given
people now a great story for the rest of
their life
he's given them a gift
to tell their future there is not anyone
on that boat that is not thinking
slightly differently about their
decisions
and sometimes the best thing anyone can
be in life is a story a cautionary Tale
a flag on a mantle
Uncle Jim gave it all for the country
because who knew what Uncle Jim would
have been doing if he didn't give it all
over the country maybe he would have
been at the barbecue getting handsy with
the kids
so just flag so Cameron who I'm sure was
a lovely guy maybe who knows I don't
know I'm sure he was
but what he's done now for these people
that were on that boat
they have one of the most amazing
Stories I would work it into everything
I don't care where I was or what I was
doing I would absolutely I would always
bring it up I would go
get this
High School
we're on a cruise in the Bahamas
all of the sudden this guy Cameron
baseball player had it all going for him
girlfriend
he's going to a good college all that
decides to jump off the boat
at 11 30 12 midnight
everybody's freaking out
then you know what happens
he's eaten by a shark
I would never I would not be in one
social Arrangement where that story was
not told
I would tell a cop who gave me a ticket
I would tell anyone there would be not
one thing I would do in my life where I
would not bring that up
getting a mortgage in a bank when they
say Mr Dylan how long have you been
employed I would go
first
High School
cruise ship in the Bahamas
good looking baseball player World At
His Feet had the girl the college
probably a good job
decides to jump off
disappears into the murky Waters eaten
by sharks right in front of us
it's the type of story that makes you
appreciate life
and by the way and I'm sad about this I
don't want this I'm against this
if I could have talked to the shark
and tried to get him
or her to behave differently I would
have but I can't but what Cameron has
done is he's given people the gift now
of a great story it is an epic tale and
it's quick that's the beauty of it it's
in and out it's not like my third
cousins
uncle
well we called him uncle but he wasn't
really related to it's none of that it's
boat in death in front of everyone and
it and and then they get to describe the
aftermath they get to describe the weird
because everyone's partying you're on
[__] Blackbeard's Adventure Cruise or
whatever white trash Festival they take
these scumbags on after they graduate
[__] gumbo high school and they're on
this boat and everybody's getting drunk
and it's what a great [__] way to
start the summer your friend gets eaten
by sharks in front of you you then get
to say to yourself well like he they're
on the phone's gone Cameron was eaten by
a [__] they're saying Cameron was
eaten by a [__] shark dude he jumped
off it's [__] nuts how fun is that
that they have that experience that
moment that bonding we should have
stopped them they said we should have
stayed never should have jumped they'll
live with that forever this kid had best
friends I'm sure they are going to maybe
he told one of them and maybe one of
them wasn't like
you know I don't know they couldn't
stand up to him because they just they
loved Cameron and Cameron he was the one
who got to do whatever he wanted to do
and
they have to live with that because
someone's inevitably gonna go did he
tell anyone did he tell anyone he was
going to jump off and then one guy is
going to be like uh he may have
mentioned it they're like and you didn't
stop him I don't know it was Cameron
let's watch it one more time again and
rip to this man but a gift a gift
not only can you see a shark in the
video oh you can you can but uh you hear
somebody in the background go bye bye
well that's interesting that shows how
callous children are now huh
that really does bye bye like that's a
real
and maybe not everybody knew him but and
violence to these kids is well it's like
a video game now it's not even real I
mean we they're in schools or preparing
to get shot every day they're doing
[__] drills I get it they're a little
cold the kids have become a little cold
but that if they saw the shark about to
eat them and they were like bye bye
unless it was a fun black chick it was
like bye bye because that would be
perfect again R.I.P to this person I
don't I'm not happy this guy perished
but it was in a way that will teach
people on everyone learns a lesson on
that boat deaths were prevented
because people are going to look at that
and they're going to go yeah maybe I
shouldn't drive 120 miles an hour to
impress my girl it's going to impact
people's behavior in a range of
different ways let's watch this video
again this is very sad a guy jumps off a
boat here
and gets eaten by a shark to teach
others
you can kind of see the shark
s
I mean it's sad it's sad because you can
you can it looks like a shark
oh boy well
we are
I'm happy about that
but it is something where you say to
yourself like
huh
it's that split-second decision
the VAC I made and when he was in the
water I wonder if he knew like when he
was in the water I wonder if he knew
that he had made the wrong decision
probably once he got in there he goes
this isn't as cool as I thought it would
be
I imagine that
president yeah we'll show you the shark
real quick oh please show me the shark
where is it
it's about three seconds in see you
coming from the left side here right oh
yeah that's right you can just see the
way it turns too
that's a shark
and then he's he's dragged under the
water
I mean you just see him swim the other
way but I think by the time anything
happens to him the boat is long gone I
think he's out of sight
so he maybe sees the shark and goes I'm
gonna get out of there yeah
wow amazing the last you know you'll
wonder the last few seconds it goes
through your head
you know
you know like the last few seconds he's
in the water he sees the shark he goes
[__] this is the cost
of Fame
on that little level
on that small
microscopic who cares
level of just being known to everyone on
the boat that's the cost of it
that's the cost of being known
wow
because it could have worked out he
could have came back on the boat
everyone could have loved him you're the
[__] craziest dude I had to do it
he's telling everyone so [__] Bahamas
man I had to do it like but it went the
other way it went the other way it's
like Britney Spears
Fame could be Tina Turner where you have
this great long career you move to
Switzerland you marry a guy who doesn't
hit you you live to Lady whatever you
enjoy yourself you're you die a legend
or fame can be Britney Spears where they
keep you in a cage for 10 years they let
you out we all go you need to go back in
and it's it's a horrifying to behold